Hi everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go ahead and take a look at the outline for
this series of videos in which we're going to be discussing how to tackle materials in
Unreal. And then from there, we're going to go ahead and dive in and talk about what exactly
is a Material, PBR, in Unreal in general. So let's get started. So one of the first things
we'll talk about is real-time material concepts. What are materials in Unreal and what is PBR,
physically based rendered material? We'll then look at primary nodes and textures,
look at primary PBR inputs, material settings, and also textures. From there, we're going to
take a look at material editor and parameter materials, look at material editor overview,
hotkeys, preview window, material system, blend and light modes, and parent materials and instances.
From there, we'll also look at making materials and parameters, editing materials, animating
materials we'll go to. And from there, we'll look at diffuse and spec setup for those animations,
pattern node and blending, rough setup, normal setup, and AO setup. And then finally, we'll look
at the cloth material options and how you can use them to your advantage and how to navigate.
All right, let's go and dive right in.
Real-time material concepts. So what is a material when it comes to real-time and working with
Unreal? It is essentially an asset applied to a mesh to control its visual look. In its simplest
form, think of it as paint with various properties such as color and finish, and the light reacts to
those properties. A material defines how light interacts with the surface it is applied to. You
can see here a little demonstration how there'll be some materials that will absorb more light,
and there'll be others with more rough detail added, and there'll be others which are smoother
and more reflective, and which the light will bounce off in on that object. So what is PBR? And
this means a physically based rendering material when it comes to Unreal, and you'll hear me say this
off and on. So it's a unified lighting and shading system that we've developed for Unreal.
It has a better approximation of light in materials and physical interaction, so it really tries to
capture what's happening in the real world. It's intuitive and consistent, physically accurate,
and uses real-world physical measurements. So PBR is a combination of the materials,
the lighting, and the exposure, and they all come together to sell the idea that this object
is living in this particular virtual world or space. Basically, we've made it so powerful that
we're really trying to push that suspension of disbelief. So you really feel you're there,
and I'm sure you've felt that at times when you play a video game, and you'll notice looking at the
product of what Unreal brings to the table, and you're like, wow, this looks super hyper-realistic.
And that's kind of what we want to go for. But we also compare things down and make things simplistic
when needed. Well, that's it with this particular video. Here's a link to allow you to dive right in
and get a little bit more understanding of how materials work. And in the next video, we're
going to take a look at the primary nodes and textures and how to work with them in Unreal.
Thanks again.